All right. Hello and welcome everyone.
This is the course active inference for
the social sciences in 2023.
It's August 30, or maybe a different
date, depending on where you are. And
today we're in the "Semiotics and
semantics" section. We'll be hearing a
lecture from Lorena Sganzerla,
and then we're going to have a little
bit of a discussion. So, Lorena, thank
you a lot for joining and off to you for
the lecture. Okay,
hello, everyone. I'm based
in Australia. Yeah, I'm Lorena. I'm
doing actually my PhD in philosophy
here. We work in cognitive sciences and
philosophy. I work with concepts and
notions of information. So I'm very
interested in foundational understanding
of cognitive sciences and information
and how these kind of things cash out.
And this is why I was interested in
talking about semantics and social
cognition to see how these things cash
out. I have a few ideas on how semiotics
can be compatible with, like, active
inference, and I try to organize a
little bit of this semiotic notion and
active inference to see if they pan out.
Maybe they don't. So let's see how it
goes. So let's
talk about active inference, formal
semantics, and social cognition.
What's up? Okay, I cannot move my Lloyds
now. I can. So I
will first have a very short
introduction for you guys I have out
here. So what are you going to do?
Like, we have a short introduction. I'm
going to talk a little bit of theories
of meaning, and then we're going to talk
a little bit the free energy principle
and active inference and how shared
symbols and social cognition can be
thought together. I bring one case that
I find interesting and then we draw some
conclusions. So let me know what you
think in the comments and after we can
have a little discussion or in the next
session.
So the
background introduction that I want to
first point to is we are talking
about biological agents and how they
act. So we are always thinking in terms
of biological agents acting to express
in ways that express informational
sensitivities to context dependent
relevance to their environment and
things that involve communities.
However, how this very minimal way of
talking about what motivates and what is
relevant to people becomes stable enough
as a self sustaining pattern of
interactions, like, are they stable and
how they become that stable? So how can
those information sensitivities ground
values, norms, and goals consistently
and over time, assuming that those
values and goals are necessary for
meaningful interactions? So we have to
align motivations to behavior, right?
That's not really obvious. And
ultimately how meaning is brought about.
I don't think I'm going to answer that,
but I want to point to some directions
and how people have been thinking about
these questions over time.
So the problem of meaning has a brief
account, right? Like, traditionally
approaches of to cognition,
localize meaning inside individual
organisms and more specifically, inside
their minds so meaning pertains to
content in this kind of thing.
However, like many have a developmental
history so it's hard to catch those two
things together if it's inside people's
minds. How we can have an evolutionary
and developmental history assuming
that meanings are things that we can
learn over time and they happen in
shared context, they don't happen out of
nowhere in a vision, from nowhere.
In a sense we can say that it's not
really trivial that conventionalized
words like for example,
the conventionalized meaning of a word,
for instance, catch means catch, have
evolutionary histories one thing does
not come from the other. We need a
broader understanding to cash this
meaning out and that's where I'm
stepping from. That's my grounding. We
need to cast these things out in terms
of community of language users which
brings a problem, right? We have goals
and values that can be defined in terms
of those communities and you have
material embodied factors. So how these
two things are together or how
goals and values affect and motivate
material and embodied agents?
To answer this kind of question, like
over time, there are a few preferred
ways. I will do a brief overview
of some theories of meaning usually in
terms of cognitive sciences and any
philosophy of mind. That's what I'm
interested in how they cast it out.
They usually try to think of those
things in terms of syntax like concerns
with form as an abstract organizing
kind of rule is a type of grammar and
how the order of things and how the
logical unfolding of those symbols,
how they become meaningful. But the
syntax itself is not really enough to
cash out meaning in semantics. So then
in that sense syntax evolve into a field
that we call semantics, in which meaning
and mental content are organized.
Throughout this instructional syntax
then we have propositional knowledge and
truth conditions in which allows these
organizational story of meaningful words
to make sense and they're going to point
out into the outside world. And we have
a third option it's not so new,
but it's not so famous, which is
semantics. Or more importantly, I will
focus on biosemantics.
It concerns with the use of symbols like
how they bring about meaning in terms of
pragmatics and that will be a little bit
different and we'll catch it out in
different terms in relation to
its peers like semantics and syntax.
Well, syntax is pretty clear in terms of
being rules, right? So what is semantics
talk about? So talk about mental
content, about intentionality, about
mental representations in the sense we
have semantics that have specific key
concepts that reference truth conditions
and denotation. So if you have mental
content and if you put these meanings
inside the organism, it has to refer to
something else. And how this cognitive
penetration happens. Like, how can
meaning come about inside the mind?
And how that refers to something outside
in the world and how this observational
viewpoint of you thinking about
something in front of you can be
actually true. So we need truth
conditions that denote this specific
relationship and that is represented
in terms of mental content
contemporarily there's like various ways
of catching this out that can be
functional, that can be more
internalized mental specific types of
representations grounded in vehicles.
It's a very rich discussion and I don't
want to go into all that. I just want to
point it out that science and
neuroscience use those terms to study
and to build models that relate to
mental representations in terms of neuro
representations because it kind of makes
sense for us like brain activity. You
can see them in terms of what happens by
studying human beings and by studying
animals and how these mental
representations relate to something that
happens in the world. You can see that
one behavior elicits specific activities
and they have a correlational
relationship and that is highly
debated. But there we go. We have many
types of cashing out neural
representations and concerning to this
relationship of stimuli and the
interpretation of this stimuli and how
they motivate action.
That's already a very much weaker claim
in relation to mental content and things
being inside organisms but it is still
in the same line of reasoning.
And there is also biosemiotics which I
want to focus a little bit more because
it concerns the use and the
interpretation of signs and symbols
which also emphasizes the
embodied nature and the situated nature
of meaning. So you don't have meaning
without those practices and without the
use of embodied agents.
So we have to reject the idea that
meaning are abstract symbols or they
going to be something that has to be in
your mind and refer to something
outside. They're going to only exist in
this type of relationship and they can
take many forms including chemical
signals like visual clues, behavior,
words like the word cat you can have how
you organize the word cat. They are all
symbolic and that fits also in that kind
of structure. So they are very important
for communication, obviously because we
do communicate in terms of pointing to
the same shared notions of symbols in
words and also other types of symbolic
meaning and we coordinate life around
them. So living systems are then here
characterized by the biosemite
semiotics, by their ability of creating
and interpreting and using these symbols
in terms of their practices. The fathers
of biosemiotics started
probably in the 19th century and Ox
Cole is one of the most famous
representatives. Currently you can find
new authors like Hoffman, Maya or
Baker. So I tried
to organize a little bit in
a specific model, in a type of model,
in a visual story, how these two
types of understanding meaning are being
applied in terms of theories
of meaning historically.
So in biosemiotics we have the
pragmatics and you have the practice and
they relate to dynamics and context
dependent. So you can see here on the
top of the screen how agent we have the
agent relationship with its
psychological and social aspects and
biosemiotics is somewhat concerned how
correlation leads to prediction and
beliefs and that leads to expectations.
And we also have other types of theories
like telesymantics and and theories
of computational syntax that tries to
understand the dynamics and the
mechanism of this relationship.
And they are not really crossing each
other.
They're not talking about the same
necessary things. So how can these
things be brought together?
That's when I was thinking how we can
bring this free energy principle and
active inference in terms of those
relationships. The free
energy principle and active inference,
as we know and I have been talking about
probably in the past two classes.
It's a model that is interesting for
that because it has like very minimal
assumptions. So it starts off from the
idea that organisms act to maintain
themselves in their expected biological
and cognitive states. So you're always
talking, you're modeling and using these
mathematicals to ground biological
agents in a very embodied sense.
And they do so by minimizing their free
energy. Right? So they have these
metabolical states that have to be
minimized in terms of expenditure,
in terms of uncertainty. Given that the
long term average of free energy is
entropy, they want to minimize their
uncertainty in terms of their
metabolical states. What that entails
that they have a specific range of
states they want to stay in, like
minimally to stay alive. To stay alive,
you have to do a bunch of things as a
human being, but every single embodied
agent would you prefer to stay alive?
So there are some preferred basic states
that we've defined how action will be
take first to maintain metabolical
states and how that coordinate with the
environment,
which entails that organisms
and agents can be described in those
terms. Like an active inference tries to
bring out those minimal assumptions in
mathematical terms that try to express
how reducing the probability of these
non anticipated states or states that
are not favorable to maintaining their
minimal metabolical needs will
be reduced. Right? And that can be
catched in terms of a generative model,
as we've been saying throughout the past
actions, how this generative model sets
specific times and organizes around
specific parameters that can
be described as trying to maintain those
parameters within reasonable range.
So by minimizing free energy on
average and over time, this system will
self organize. So we will bring out the
parameters of its internal states that
occupy a limited number of possible
states. We will set into a specific
range that will then be then
will be used as somewhat the base
and the guide for this behavior. You
have two kinds of dynamics
happening here, right? That's what I
want to talk about a little bit. So we
have then a phenotype that exists in a
specific type of states, but that will
have to coordinate two different kinds
of dynamics. They're going to be stated
here as complementary, right? You have
flow states and have belief updating.
So with flow states you have one type of
modeling which is the known equilibrium
steady states that we use intrinsic is
named here intrinsic information
geometry and you have belief updating
that can be treated as extrinsic
informational geometry and those are
different types of modeling
or different types of thinking about
those processes that's most important,
right? So in terms of flow states we
can talk about dynamical system and how
you settle and self organize specific
parameters. And in terms of belief
updating we will be talking about
Bayesian mathematics and Bayesian
cognition and specific
ways of cashing out how an agent will
change and behave over time in relation
to the dynamics that is
set into place in this state space of
possible actions.
So while dynamical systems will explore
temporal and contextual, dependence
between environment and agent will set
this specific state space that has
temporal dimension and has contextual
dimension. And once this state space is
sort of established, we have more or
less deterministic
approach to what can possibly
unfold. So how changes and
how behavior can be cashed out in
terms of nondeterministic behavior and
that is defined by the different type of
probabilistic thinking
which is the Bayesian mechanics of
belief, of belief updating. So we have
then a process of belief updating
throughout weighted interactions within
this range of possible
states. So we do have dynamics
and we do also have biasian process
unfolding together in terms of
mechanisms. And with that
we do have mathematical statements
providing a unifying perspective on
formal approaches connecting behavior
and dynamics. So that's what
active inference should be bringing
about as a novelty in relation to older
forms of understanding organisms which
can either cash things out in term of
behavior or in terms of dynamics. So
trying to bring these two things
together is quite interesting to
understand how symbols and what is
semantics for instance? So that's
the question I will be asking right now.
Let's talk a little bit about that.
I'm drawing here from quite interesting
paper from Maxwell
Ramstead and in politely is
free energy principle a principle for
formal semantics? So what would be
formal semantics? It sounds like an
oxymoron, right? Like how semantics can
be formal, how can you formalize it? So
semantics, the theory of meaningful
things. So how can that be empty of
content? Well, it has
a few principles in which you can
explain what formal semantics should how
a formal semantics should be understood.
First off, we have Bayesian formalism
that does not necessarily have to commit
to classical notions of representations
which are propositional in nature, have
propositional semantic content. So the
idea is that you can use the notion
of a representation in a way that is not
necessarily contentful. So how that's
going to be? So under the free energy
principle, representations can be
formal. That's the argument they are
bringing under the physics of flow,
specifically dynamical system theories
and information geometry you can have
these mathematical statements that only
represent possible specific
ways of interacting, how these
correlations will affect each other over
time in this variational base type of
cashing out mathematical functionals.
In this sense, we can talk about
representational, how they can be
understood under this formalism. And
what they are saying is they are best
understood as internal structures that
enable the system to parse out their
sensory sensitivities or the sensory
streams. So to organize them in specific
parameters and also in the terms of
their own Markov blankets in their
blanket states,
which is interesting here. What is the
new genealogy of this paper is that
grounding a mathematical model in these
mathematical properties of the system
will avoid grounding these
properties in terms of the properties of
symbols and thematics in abstract or
subjective notions of meaning, but
impossible ranges of action.
So summing up, what we had before was a
type of computational model that had
specific components that does not allow
for the intelligibility intelligibility
of a cognitive component which is
intention, which is motivation,
context, brain, computer metaphors. We
have neuro and cognitive activity often
seen as a transfer of symbolic
information and cognition, then a
snapshot of this transfer. So it's
totally dependent of that kind of
symbolical transfer which is really
difficult to explain how that's going to
be biologically plausible and there's a
lot of effort trying to do that. So if
you're interested in this, there's a
very vast wealth of literature but they
have to answer to this problem. So how
the mind and brain needs to produce an
impromptu response to inputs of the
external environment all the time and
the idea of this formal semantics the
authors is trying to explain is trying
to include this component into the
model. So you have a deflationary model
about content, so you have a formal
semantics, you have semantics without
content. Interestingly and formulated as
a variation
of free energy functional. So those
structures that embody those process
correspond to states in the system and
we also have the biological component
that can be formalized
in terms of disturb informational
geometry that these two densities do
probabilistic densities, one from the
dynamics and one from the Bay agent
describing behavior and
now what? So how can active inference be
compatible to biosematics? Can it be
actually compatible or is it even
necessary?
Well, active inference is a
very general framework and then it does
not really give us the tools to
understand how encoding can happen
in terms of symbols, like how
they can be broadcasted into collective
action because prediction alone does not
explain how do they come about. So in
this sense we do have meaningful
correlations that refer
to the dynamics of one or two or more
systems in terms of informational
geometry that needs to
be cached out with predictive value. So
how is this possible?
Well, we can talk about that in terms of
shared attention. That's one form of
this kind of model to cash this out. So
we have active inference capturing
relevant statistical relations between
environment and aging. And why
I'm trying to think about here is how
biosyniotics offer tools for these
informational sensitivities and
statistical relations to cache symbols
in terms of use and interpretation
within communities of language users.
And that can only happen in the sense
via directed action. So the problem now
will turn into how is it possible to
specify the factors that are sufficient
to constrain action and direct
that into specific interaction
fault is through the history interaction
fault is European forestry.
I'm picking this example from a very
like from James,
I really recommend kind of tells this
story about how coordinated action,
how states coordinate specific
collective actions. But that's not the
point that I want to talk here. So here,
let's unfold that a little bit in terms
of the design of scientific forestry and
think about scientific forestry as a
practice. And a practice that has an
organizing principle that will like
that will be the main important
articulating story that can
connect together how agriculture layouts
plantations in specific ways and how
collective farms will make specific
choices in terms of this organization
and how villages can structure
themselves around one specific notion
or one specific organizational principle
and how everything can be calculated to
make one type of
practice, which is agriculture is a very
general, more legible and more
manipulable for different
kinds of communities. So in that we will
involve manipulating the very concrete
aspects of the land, the terrain,
the products, the workforce. So it has a
very encompassing effect over time and
in a very concrete sense.
And interestingly when you talk about
European forestry and how European
forestry was modeling the terrain and
how it's catching out value of these
terrains. They were not trying to do
that to successfully depict the full
range of diversity of the actual social
activity and the actual activity
of agriculture or the richness of the
vegetation or they are not even trying.
They didn't intend to do that. That was
not the point of this kind of modeling
turned into a practice, right? Those
models generally represent
specific slices of nature that were
interesting for one specific official
observer. And that
point is really important because that
will shape how all these communities
and how the terrain and how the forest
will unfold over time within this
specific perspective.
So I bring here a quote that I really
really like because it tries to flesh
this out in simple terms and very useful
ones. So, thinking that
exaggerating only slightly, one might
say that the interest in forest was
resolved through one fiscal specific
single number, which was the revenue
that yield from the timber that was
extracted annually. Well, that's okay,
that's understandable, that's
intelligible and that happens to you
every day. In terms of how we understand
our economy but what is interesting
about this quote is that the best way to
appreciate how heroic was this
constriction of vision is to notice what
falls outside the field of vision. So
what is missing from that is not the
organizational principle of timber being
valuable but everything that was not
there or was being excluded treason
bushes and planters and plants that hold
little to non potential for that
purpose. So missing out of that is
floridiversity foliage, fruits, et
cetera, twigs and branches. Missing out
of that are insects and small animals.
Depending on this diversity, all this
ecological organization falls out of
the organizational principle and that
has very concrete consequences that we
still suffer. Her we still live in the
height of this climate
crisis that also starts from this kind
of thinking. So it has really very
material consequences for us and had for
them at the time, if you read more about
it, that a timber, by trimming and
domesticating nature, so much decreased
in quality and then eventually decreased
in value, which prompted them to try to
reorganize that kind of story.
And what? I want to call attention with
the example is that also it brings some
specific ways of talking about it. It
brings vocabulary that only exists
in terms of this type of practice
specifically. So this vocabulary
constrains nature in a way by pruning
what cannot be used. So it generates
more than a legible nature, but a way of
making nature intelligible and
intelligible in a very specific certain
way. And we make that happen in terms of
symbolizing things in specific terms.
But the symbols, they don't exist in
themselves. They exist only in
organizing the social practice around
them. So when you replace nature with a
term called natural resources, we are
doing exactly that. It's specifying from
a generalized notion of nature like
flora and fauna becomes something
valuable, becomes a commodity but
not everything, right? It trims the
practice. It separates competing species
from value goods. So plants are
symbolized as crops and the
competing species are symbolized as
weeds. They are not necessarily crops or
weeds or anything like that in nature,
but they are that for the way we talk
like that because we practice
agriculture in a certain way.
That's the same for insects or small
animals that consume these interesting
crops. So the
material effect of that and how that
only gains traction in the practice over
time and how you have specific intention
that has unintended consequences are
necessarily here situated contextualized
and embodied in terms of trimming
specific types of attention. And this
attention will only shift to try
to repopulate infect population, for
instance, when you realize that this
practice brought this specific effect in
a certain way that affects the value of
our understanding of nature and
that generates exactly a type of social
coherence and social coordination and
how constraints create this coherence,
right?
Well now let's talk back
again about formal semantics.
While this formal semantics and active
inference sort of embeds one type of
mathematical formalism symbols
can only be grounded in specific
concrete practices or inaction.
So while active inference can be used as
a tool to explain social understanding,
it does do that in terms of generalized
synchronization in a model of cognition
that can be inactive and dynamic. But
this is still very general in terms of
biosematics. We can think of it
as a framework that might be compatible
with active inference in terms of
explaining the materiality of the
environment in a non reductive, in a non
reductionist way that tries to retain
some naturalistic credentials. So how
the conventions are affecting and
affecting the embodied agent in terms of
forming those symbols and cashing out
those epistemic values.
And well
social interaction in this sense is not
reduced to prediction because in this
sense, the prediction will not be a
primitive, but it will be a
result of a specific participatory
construction of the social scene over
specific. Organizational principles
and actions that,
through the synchronization of these
generative models, or the
synchronization of those agents that can
be described in terms of those
generative models, gain predictive
value. And when you model that then you
have this type of understand the value
of prediction in those senses.
So that
allows that
allows us to say that social actors in
this sense can behave as if they have a
generative model that synchronizes with
that symbolic state of affairs allowing
them to understand each other's
behaviors or to develop approximate
informational sensitive or
responsiveness to the same symbols and
goals. They are approximate because
they're obviously not going to be the
same but they have the
same approximate orientation.
So in this sense, we don't have ever
a view from nowhere. We don't have ever
this view that is only cashed out in
terms of specific types of minds. But
you also have types of minds shaped in
terms of these very concrete
organizations.
That happens in a community, like for
humans at least, it happens in community
of language users. So their relationship
with symbolic cues helps to
select attention at that specific time
as well. Pruning what should be ignored
in socially constructed environments.
So within a specific community
of language users some types of actions
will be desirable and will be deemed
as true in that specific type of
community and can be only evaluated
under those terms. So you can provide
reasons for actions in
that specific context and you can
talk about how rational
that action is in terms of the
conditions set by those communities.
And that brings us to the idea that
human cognition in this sense is never
decoupled from these cultural norms that
pushes and orients them over time. So in
those scale of behavior and that's the
interesting thing. And that's why active
inference can be an interesting tool to
model this type of human communities and
this type of behavior because it can
come from the very dynamics, the very
basic of dynamics to specific types of
perception and scale up and more.
So when you have the problem of symbols,
like in these two decoupled possible
community of users and symbols and
embodied agents and things that do not
combine, we can try to model
our agents in a way that we don't have
this problem anymore because you're
trying to include that very component
into the model.
So in this sense, we have active
inference used as tools to explain
social understanding, as generalized
synchronization and in understanding
others. In that sense, because of this
generalized synchronization model and
assumed by those types of organizational
principles, we can also engage in terms
of niche construction. So we have a more
or less deterministic way of
understanding the nature
of symbols because the more we interact
and approximate synchronize with the
environment, we change the environment
that might change us back. So you have
an open system that is always and
everywhere situated and key can be
modeled then with this type of
predictive value. So that's
more or less what I had in mind and
that's how I was trying to think about
biosemiotics and in a possible
relationship with free
energy principle and the formalisms of
yeah, I think this is it.
Awesome. Thank you, Lorena. I'll just
organize things a little in my room.
But thank you very much for this
excellent lecture. Just as a kind of
warm up, how did you come to see it
this way? What brought you to this
general question of semantics and how
do you see that like on your own path
and see what other comparable or
analogous approaches have been done in
terms of a meta analysis and proposal
related to the naturalization of
semantics?
I think it's kind of hard to naturalize
semantics, right? I think there's a lot
of effort in doing that. And it might be
that if you think differently about how
we naturalize those values,
we might have better answers.
Instead of trying to fit the agent into
the model, we try to fit the model into
the agent. Right? I think that was the
motivation. I think there's the
interesting part of biosymptics in that
sense. It tries to make less
assumptions. When we start
from a hardcore assumption or model
assumption, right. That semantics is
only within the mind, then we have a
very hard time trying to explain that.
If you assume less about that, you might
bring different types of explanations,
of course, but they'd
be more interesting. I was trying to see
how that looks like when you bring these
two things together in the terms of
active inference and free energy
principle, if that works, if that is
possible. I don't know if that answers
your question.
So wondering about that fundamental
question and then coming across active
inference or how elsewhere have people
brought in the more formal and technical
into this question?
What do you mean by more formal? And can
you repeat that, please? Yeah. How does
active inference help us or have
continuity or difference with previous
ways that people have connected? The
technical part from what
you described as the formal semantics
embeds the mathematical formalism, and
then the symbols are grounded in
specific action. So has that been played
out in other technical frameworks?
Well, we do have technical frameworks
that try to organize that in terms of an
activism right. And autopoietic and
activism. But then we just have in these
terms, the notion of symbols sometimes
get loosely described. And I think these
guys are not really interested in that.
I think they're trying to describe
something else, for example, or you can
have some specific types of
computational if you
really buy into the mind computational
brain and computational mind metaphor,
then you have a hard time also to
explain how semantics are built into
that computation. Right. I don't think
anyone has a very strong answer to that.
You have to really buy into the idea of
information processing. And that's what
brought me a little bit to that. If you
buy into the metaphor of information
processing, then you need to have
semantics within the brain. If you try
to lose a little bit this notion, if you
try to understand process and
information in different terms, what
happens? I think that was more or less
the question that I was trying to ask.
And if active inference and biosemiotics
can, because they have less assumptions
in terms of what happens inside
the processing information content in
the mind,
if that can bring interesting answers or
if you can use as a model to organize
behavior.
And there's another point that also
brought me to this type of thinking,
was trying to understand how
active inference can include the
historicity of the agent. Right.
Because I think that something comes
across debated in active
inference, how you bring novelty into
the state space. Like, once you define
that state space, the state space is
more or less deterministic because
everything will happen within that
specific range. So how does novelty
comes within this type of
modeling? So how can you explain that
if it does? I don't know.
It's more like an exploratory question
that I was trying to make and see how
that pans out. I actually also don't
have an answer for that. But if
you take seriously some more inactive
claims that you need history of
interactions to understand how agents
behave, you cannot understand agents
without that. So how does
active inference answer this question
specifically? Right,
because once yeah, I think that's still
kind of debated. I'm not sure if there's
new developments in this specific topic,
but I remember I think two years ago was
like this specific papers from
Di Paulo. I think the Lane dawa Forking
path is specifically focusing on that in
the formalisms and et cetera. So I don't
know if these two things can bring a
little bit of more to the conversation,
maybe not. Great.
I'll just ask some more general
questions. You're adding a lot with
these thoughts. So you said that social
interaction in this account is not
reduced to prediction. So how would you
unpack that and how would you relate
this? I don't know exactly
what term of art would go here, but this
kind of social epistemology that active
inference provides us in contrast to
say, predictive processing. So how is it
that we would or wouldn't reduce
something to prediction? And then what
is it that active inference brings into
that discussion? Yeah, well,
I think I have two points in that.
Like, active inference in that sense has
a type of modeling that tries to include
all the time and everywhere the embodied
agent. If you take seriously the idea,
the generative model is always
accurately modeling that
specific agent because it
cannot be true or false, your current
state is like that even if you are not
feeling really well, you just know that
you're not feeling well in relation to
something else. And that story
is still very accurate to your state
condition right now. Right.
So the prediction gains traction
socially at least in that sense, not in
this specific detail of predictive
processing, I think, because I think
that's more complicated. But socially,
in social cognition, at least we can
talk about this predictive value, I
think is a more interesting way to do
that because the
example that I use in terms of catching
out symbols, we are using something that
was meant to make something
intelligible that have very bad
consequences that were not even close to
be predicted. So in that sense and how
these consequences happen, prediction
cannot be there everywhere and all the
time. The prediction has an orientation
as well, right? So that's going to
unfold only in terms of the orientation,
but that's not all encompassing.
What does that say about the prediction?
That's why I was trying to think of it
as not being a primitive, but something
that comes along with these dynamics.
Well, this is a very deep impresscient
point that because the causal structure
of the world changes, historiosity
agents change, they learn and they
attend, and then the niche changes with
stigma g and niche modification. So
because things really do change through
time, then just training a
data set at one time point and
then using that same generative model
and carrying it forward, it's like
picking a speed in a direction when
you're on a winding road and just
saying, all right, now let's turn on
cruise control right now and just keep
going in this direction. It's working
right now. So then
to connect that to the legibility of the
forests as the causal model changed and
externalities were not taken into
account and so on, all these different
features you brought in. So now is
active inference and cognitive modeling,
cognitive technologies increasing our
legibility of perception, cognition and
action through surveillance technology
and other mechanisms such that there
could be we expect there to be
also hidden dynamics
and externalities that we are also
failing to see when we make some aspects
of cognitive systems legible in the way
that research in the neurosciences is
happening towards.
Yeah, I think in the sense if you're
trying to do that, you cannot have a no
like in a model that encompasses
everything, right, that would be non
informative in terms of when you do
that, you're interested in something,
right? You have one thing in mind when
you're trying to flesh out in terms of
cognitive modeling, how that applies to
these more all encompassing situations.
I think that's like that model is how
I'm trying to ask this question. So you
can model them in this sliced sense and
that's what we do as scientists and
that's how we learn about things. But
that only way of seeing that very
specific model is not all encompassing
for all answers. How can you use that
in comparison to other situations?
So how can you integrate this type of
thing? I don't know. I don't have a
question and an answer for that. I don't
know if we do have an answer for this
type of question currently.
But I think it's a very valid question
to ask because
also in the terms of sometimes applying
that socially, that sort of raifies
in a way and then it becomes an
organizing principle that becomes
somewhat raified. So keep an eye for
these kinds of metaphorical use, like
assuming a little bit that all this talk
can be metaphorical and it can be
interesting and useful to catch them out
in these terms because they don't have
other ways to talk about them.
So how we don't Raify them
and how they are,
because I'm
having a hard time to get there, but I
think I'm making the point of people
criticizing the causal primacy. So when
you reduce these complex systems to one
single cause, cashing out everything
that organizes these complex systems in
one primal cause,
then you are losing the complexity.
However, if you don't do that, how can
you slice it out to understand the
system? So I think that's the two
tensions here that I'm kind of trying to
propose as a question instead of an
answer. I don't know if that makes
sense, but are you thinking, yeah, I
hope. People continue that discussion.
I'm going to build on that just to kind
of maybe circle around that because it's
really important. So in the forestry
case, the realist perspective,
again using retro casting the way we
or contemporary discussions, some of
them in the active inference and free
energy principle space are the realist
says that region of land is just
economic potential. It is a natural
resource that becomes a kind of handle.
The instrumentalist perspective takes a
step back and says it's as if that piece
of land is a natural resource. So,
yeah, the territory is indescribable and
there's still a space for mystery. But
then when the proxies come out because
policies are being selected, the as if
in some ways carries similar
consequences to the actual and
they may totally agree and the realists
and the instrumentalists might be like,
yeah, it is economic potential or
represents or it could be treated as
such or it could be engaged with as such
that cognitive diversity can align on
the social policy that then
connects to these broader social
questions and histories. And so it's
kind of interesting, like, what work
does this instrumentalism do? Like, oh,
it's just a principle. What work
does it do and what doesn't it do? And
the ways that science and technical
engineering fields are and aren't
deployed alone or together with
other considerations. Yeah, that's very
interesting in the sense I don't know if
you're realist or instrumentalist about
that, if you think models are not either
true or false, they're just models,
right. They might have used and they
might be capturing real properties.
But the problem is, in this
conversation, even when you push them,
like have realists and have an
instrumentalist try to loosen up a
little bit these assumptions, they still
end up refine those principles and
taking them to be more or less true or
false. Right? Well, that's kind of a
plot twist. It's like you're appealing
to what surprise, minimization as
unifying the diversity responses
that the realist and instrumentalists
do. So then does that make surprise or
cognitive inertia, like the er principle
where the maze just ends and it explains
itself? Or how does that play in a
pluralistic scientific setting?
Yeah,
you can have a third answer to that.
I think the answer that I'm trying to
give is more eliminativist in the sense
that eliminates the cause of primacy of
them, of these two modes of answering.
I'm thinking I have in mind now,
actually, just to try to make sense of
that. When you think about biological
information, you can think about
biological information as being real,
as being metaphorical and instrumental.
Or you have these guys like Susan Oyama
or Richard lewantin, they try to bring
some they are against this cause of
primacy. They try to advocate for
systems that do have that, but they have
a lot of more going on. So that cannot
be the only answer because those systems
are not everywhere scientifically.
They don't have to be everywhere. That,
for example, going back to the forestry.
So the realist is going to say that
territory is valued property in
the sense the instrumental is going to
say, look as if it can be used as
if but it's not necessarily value
property. It doesn't matter. You can say
like, well, this terrain is
seen from one perspective as value
property, but it also has other uses
around them. So you had to be more
inclusive of this diversity because the
only organizational principle around
that specific terrain is not only
to generate value or if it does, this
value doesn't have one single output.
It can have more than one output in
terms of very specific terms. You can
cash it out very materially. This
terrain that has to provide monoculture,
has to provide also value for the
diversity of the fauna and the diversity
of the flora around it. And that is not
included in a model because that's not
what the model is done for. The model
has a specific use and that's fine.
However, that does not reduce the
terrain to that.
Well when you're talking about
cognition, that might be more
complicated, but I think it's an easy
way to talk about this cause of primacy
when you talk about forestry because we
are very much now experiencing this
climate crisis and we see these things
happening right now and how difficult
because this type of thinking is built
over time and so well fixed
in the way we see things and we are
understanding how hard is to change
that. It not. It's a paradigm shift
that needs to happen for that to change.
It's not necessarily the model that is
right or wrong, it's just how you
understand and apply them.
So there are pragmatics into that. It's
not only an instrumental, but it has
something that the instrumentalist take
does not capture. And I don't know how
to catch it out in one single word, but
that's what Biosimatics was offering.
Biosymiatics was offering the idea of
practice and pragmatics. I don't know if
it's the whole story, but it's another
point into that story.
A lot of great points all connect that
note of pragmatism to a little bit of
the active inference formalism. So when
it comes to policy selection, behavior
selection, some, but not all cognitive
entities can act as if they're
calculating expected free energy. So
these are the active, the truly active
entities, whether they're simple or
whether they're sophisticated and they
do planning expected free energy is how
those agents are being modeled, as if
they're making decisions. And it
consists of the pragmatic and the
epistemic value. That's how these
different policies are evaluated. And so
I see two angles
or windows that that supports,
at least from my non social sciences
background, a new kind of meeting in the
middle there. So first is the expansion
of pragmatic value under the principle
that surprise, minimization or bounding
is the imperative right there in the
pragmatic value. It doesn't have to be
just body temperature or financial
income. We can expect and prefer ourself
to be learning new things or meeting new
people. And so we can load into the
pragmatism different goals
that under a narrower definition of
utility or pragma have not traditionally
been included. So I think that first way
is it speaks to a more inclusive concept
of utility, you might say. I'm also
derisking on forest fires alongside the
timber and already you have now plural
pragma. So I think that's the kind of
crossover and then the deeper and second
and not saying there's only two ways
that the conversation continues. We have
epistemic utility in terms of epistemic
value and so the balance and the
weighting between pragmatic value and
epistemic or learning oriented activity
overall helps control a
dynamics balance with just like how
tight is the grip and the preference
overall. And maybe we have some
preference for timber to be exported
from a region but we really don't know.
We don't have long term modeling, we
don't have deep causal analysis. And so
we're going to put 5% on the pragmatic
extraction and other pragmatic features
and leave the rest of the policy in an
exploratory mode and come to
a blend that's not just on the spectrum
from explore to exploit, which is how
this has been approached in cognitive
sciences previously. It's like this is
the third thing where policies that are
on the frontier of exploring and
exploiting rise to the top through their
contributions to pragmatic and epistemic
value. And we made the model. So that
isn't to say that that is what's
happening on the ground or maybe that's
just the instrumentalist perspective.
Yeah, but if it's an instrumentalist
perspective, it might be a good one,
right? In the sense the idea of
inclusion is kind of the interesting
one. Right? Because if you refine the
notion of maximization because you can
use that in certain ways to understand
what happens within when you're modeling
something, what is the limit of that
maximization? So you can model agents
as if maximizing utility, for instance.
But maximizing utility is something that
needs to be balanced out with utility of
everyone around them. Right? And that's
not trivial how that happens. Right?
And even if it does, and even if it were
trivial, it's not something that maps
out completely identically
with every single agent.
There's going to be diversity there. So
how do you make that notion more
inclusive and less raified in that
sense? Because then if the more you
Raify, the more you single it out into
around only one general
type of understanding. So when you think
them more individually, then you
lose that strength of this one single
principle organized, one single
way of cashing out utility. That's not
the principle. Sorry. So I think that
speaks a lot with the type of
instrumental use and the type of
pragmatism, the types of application
of these practices. Right.
Remember, in the sense of the scientific
forestry, it's also a practice. It's not
something that is true in itself, it's
true in terms of practice, right, in
terms of applications, in terms of
building communities around them. So
without this use they have no grounding.
Yeah, one really strong and
salient point that I got from the
lecture was about generalized synchrony.
And it's almost funny that we have to
advocate or delineate generalized
synchrony because the alternative, the
absence of generalized synchrony is just
like kind of like an ideal gas. It's
like there wouldn't be regularities in
society, we wouldn't be clustered in
space or in time, we wouldn't have
information and communication and we
wouldn't have what differentiates a
society or a group or a civilization or
a colony or whatever from literally
anything else. So generalized synchrony
is almost like all of the space between
nothing and anything happening
and then it supports all these different
scenarios. We could have this kind
of mind in this kind of brain in this
kind of environment and this kind of
niche. And so we can talk about the ant
colony foraging algorithms that work in
the desert and there might be mutual,
nonexhausted, open ended change of
algorithms and what works in a different
setting. And with humans we have
the sophistication and the history and
the scope and the scale and all of these
metas and weaving with is
and ought and our own forward going
direction, which is really the
moment where it goes from being a
forensic sociology to
the real time sense making and
action selection based upon our
cognitive models. In the broader sense,
which includes humans and non human
agents. But it's like that's when it
goes from being more than just an
understanding, when that understanding
translates to an action policy and they
do, then it matters
as much as anything does.
Yeah. One of the criticism of the active
inference, I think common is like it is
too general to single out specific
constraints that orient action.
That's what I thought thinking about how
symbols are brought about in
community of language users,
assuming that the symbols are not they
are only meaningful throughout these
histories and practices can help us to
apply this type of general yeah,
navigating specific,
well, epistemic communities. And I think
that's the work that Maho is going to
bring along in terms of epistemic
communities and then you single out in
them. So you have these communities of
language users in which specific
practices create specific orientations.
Yeah. One thought on that asking
like what does active inference or
linear regression or some other method
again, this is who knows, is this just
deep esoteric instrumentalism?
But asking what does it have to say
about this symbol? What does active
inference have to say about the letter E
in English? Can it be
as simple as to say that that's a
category error and that you could make a
toy example or a pedagogical example
where symbol one and symbol two
oscillate in a multi agent simulation or
you could make a generative model for an
alphabet and leave it abstract. But
you're never going to connect to the
historiosity and the real enactment of
the English letter E unless you're
confronting the minute particulars
and the actual embodiment of that
letter. And then there's different
course grainings, different iterated
modeling decisions, different questions
about how do you include and participate
in the different stages of the
scientific process. But it's like you're
in the specifics at that point, active
inference doesn't have an opinion on the
letter E because we wouldn't want it to.
It would be too opinionated about the
wrong things. It'd be making assumptions
and bringing axioms into play that would
be extremely constraining and
so it remains general as a framework and
the free energy principle even more
differently. So but when we get into the
actual, that's where we're connecting to
the real systems of interest. But how
could we make claims and advance them
socially about systems of interest when
we're not even it's like comparing
bridge building as a concept with this
bridge right here. It's a little bit
like a category disconnect.
Yeah, well, it depends also how you
single out some things. You just don't
do that because they're just not
interesting enough. Right. There's
nothing that comes out of it in
terms of this bridge right here in a
single how did you put it again? Like a
category of bridges and this bridge
right here, right when you do that you
can learn something about the category
in terms of this single one right here.
But it's not exhaustive that's
I think one point it's not exhaustive
and it's not right or wrong. It might be
better than other I
think they did you can make some
comparisons in terms of predictive
value. You can have better or worse ways
of doing it and then it gains more
utility. Okay, connecting this to
also this non exhaustive nature
and where the power of a generalizable
framework is let's talk about the
category of Golden Gate Bridges in San
Francisco. So there's only one actual
bridge there, but we're generalizing it.
And so somebody makes a state space and
says well, I'm exploring if there was
more than two end to end. So they're
exploring the state space of topologies
of bridge and someone else is exploring
the state space of color and somebody
else is exploring the state space of
traffic dynamics and someone else is
combining two of them or combining all
three of them. And then that's the
conversation is which map of this
category of state spaces,
category of adjacent possibles as we
chose to model it. And if you don't
include traffic flow, don't be surprised
that it's not going to take that kind of
data or make that kind of prediction.
And some variables matter and some
matter in combination and some don't.
But when we model, we kind of build
these regions or adjacencies
to the actual which is where the
historiosity of the past leaves us.
And then we have an adjacent possible as
modelers and sense makers including
absurd counterfactuals and state spaces
and then the state spaces are mobilized.
Yeah, in a way. But if you talk about
specific type of engineering yes, in
that sense they are mobilized and they
are not true or false. You can use false
models that still function.
You can have specific uses of things
that you know they're not really true.
Like the thing, the taleric
type of modeling,
the solar system, they still use that to
navigate in the desert even though it's
not really accurate. But if you want to
go from A to B, it helps you to do that,
that's a different thing. Right.
It's not true or false, but when you
think about agents in terms of and if
bringing back to the idea of symbols
being only cashed out in terms of
community of users that have histories
and they are made useful, they are made
meaningful in terms of their practices,
then you don't have ever this
disconnect, right? You can think about
this cognition is always connected to
this specific types of practicing. You
can even single out some moments of it
and try to see what you learn from this
kind of slice of time.
But when you think about the whole story
of the cognitive system, if you're going
to really think of it in terms that is
valuable, you cannot disconnect from the
state, let's say the state space of its
practice.
Awesome. Well.
Do you have any closing thoughts
or what are you looking forward to with
the discussion section and the rest of
the course? Just by way of wrapping up
and letting people know? Any other
thoughts? Yeah, would be cool to explore
this idea that we've been actually
bringing along here, right? How we can
go with that instrumentally,
realistically or how can we understand
this general synchronization of the
model in terms of specific
instantiations and how informative
they are? Is that really interesting?
Or how can these things
be actually raised in terms of modeling?
And if that happens, does that have any
specific consequences actually or not?
Maybe not.
Awesome. Well, very ambitious
and excellent lecture. So thank you very
much Lorena, and talk to you.
Just keep in mind I was just like trying
to ask these questions. I don't also
have those answers. I found very little
about active inference and semiotics
produced. I found a few papers.
So that's very exploratory actually. So
you're invited to think of these things
and explore a little bit them further if
it's possible. Cool. Epic. All right.
Thank you, Lauren. I see you in a couple
of weeks. Farewell. Ciao.